we have a number of recurring
anti-immigrant stereotypes and talking
points that we hear in the United States
one of them is Oh undocumented
immigrants commit more violent crime
right well those are that's that's a
stereotype that's debunk able
statistically it also doesn't really
pass the logic test right if you are
here in an undocumented manner why would
you be more likely to draw more
attention to yourself which could lead
to you getting deported than someone who
is in the United States legally who has
no fears of being deported it just
doesn't make sense and it's not true and
we've debunked it in detail another
stereotype or anti-immigrant talking
point that we hear is that immigrants in
general documented undocumented both are
quote taking our jobs we have yet
another report this one published by the
National Academies of Sciences
engineering and medicine and it tells us
the bottom I'll bottom-line it for you
first and then dig into it more bottom
line immigrants do not take quote
American jobs there are some caveats to
the study and we'll discuss them because
it is interesting but first we have to
talk about the absurdity of this I don't
want to get into the details before I
talk about the absurdity of this most of
the jobs in the US if you haven't
noticed are being done by first second
or third generation immigrants right I
mean that's what this country is sort of
based on and at some point
either you or your parents or their
parents at some point someone that is
near and dear to you was probably one of
these immigrants taking the jobs of
whoever was here before them okay let's
put that aside and now deal with the
details of the study
once you accept and understand the
absurdity of this idea we can get into
the report first of all because of the
jobs that immigrants are most likely to
obtain this report found that when
measured over a period of 10 years or
more the impact of immigration on the
wages of native born workers overall is
very very small it's almost nothing at
all ok to the extent that negative
impacts on wages occur they're most
likely to effect prior immigrants or
native
warned workers who haven't completed
high school who are often the closest
substitutes for the jobs that immigrant
workers specifically low-skilled
immigrant thats number one okay number
two there's very little evidence that
immigration significantly affects the
overall employment levels of native-born
workers
similar to with the wage issue there's
some evidence that recent immigrants
reduce the employment rate of the
immigrants immediately prior to them but
not beyond that and that's sort of
perfectly logical intuitively
immigration overall actually has a
positive impact on long-run economic
growth in the United States we've
discussed this extensively and in terms
of fiscal impact first-generation
immigrants are more costly to
governments particularly at the state
and local level not really at the
federal level compared to native-born
individuals this is partially due in
large part to the cost of educating the
children of those immigrants however as
adults the children of immigrants right
the second generation are among the
strongest economic and fiscal
contributors in the u.s. population and
we could sort of speculate about sort of
culturally ideologically why it is that
that may be but the bottom line is they
contribute more in taxes than either
their parents or the rest of the
native-born population lastly I want to
remind you and this is not from the
study but something we've researched
extensively and reported to you about
there are undocumented immigrants who
are paying into services that because
they are undocumented they will never
actually pull money out of they will
never receive benefits from and that is
it's not insignificant that can be
measured and it's a very very positive
impact on the economy lastly numbers as
I accidentally punch my microphone and I
apologize for that I know it's a much
bigger deal to people listening than it
is to me here in the room the number of
unauthorized immigrants arriving in the
u.s. reached more than 800,000 annually
between 2000 and 2005 however after 2007
the
number of undocumented immigrants coming
into the u.s. has dropped drastically
we've seen also at this point that we
are seeing about the same number of
undocumented immigrants 400,000 leave
every year as the number that comes back
and you will often not hear that we hear
just about the inflow net though we at
this point do not seem to be
experiencing an increase in the number
of undocumented immigrants coming into
the country we have so many issues that
are just way way bigger than this the
the idea that we are going to focus on
this issue I am not advocating for
people to break the law by coming into
this country illegally you know that I
don't do that but think for a second
about the real problems that we have the
banking crisis of 2008 nothing to do
with legal or undocumented immigrants
the constant war industrial complex
including middle-east wars not caused by
immigrants if anything it contributes to
the refugee situation that we find
ourselves in the explosive growth and
income and wealth inequality combined
with the effective oligarchy that we
have in our country and the
disproportionate power of huge
corporations not caused by immigrants
the fact that health insurance is a
for-profit commodity to be bought and
sold that has nothing to do with
immigrants what this is really about is
something very common which is it's
about figuring out who you can blame
right across the last I don't know 2000
years in much of the world it's been a
lot of blame the Jews stuff immigrants
are now taking up some of that in the
United States but really it is code for
Hispanic and Muslim immigrants not
actually all immigrants and it is really
really effective especially politically
to have someone to nicely and neatly
blame for problems and sadly to too many
people it doesn't matter what some study
says by some legitimate agency many
people feel like immigrants are taking
their jobs and that's really what
matters many of our viewers and
listeners know that just posting your
job listing on one website isn't enough
to find quality candidates if you want
to find
perfect hire you really need to post
your job on all the top job sites and
now you can with zip recruiter dot-com
you can post your job to 100 plus job
sites including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter all with a
single click you can find candidates in
any city any industry nationwide just
post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into zip recruiters easy
to use interface no juggling emails no
juggling calls to your office you can
quickly screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person quickly find out
today why zip recruiter has been used by
over a million businesses and right now
david pakman show listeners can post
jobs on zip recruiter for free by going
to zip recruiter dot-com slash free
trial that is zip recruiter dot-com
slash free trial one more time try it
for free at zip recruiter dot-com slash
free trial